to show you again those pictures from
earlier of taliban fighters behind the
desk of the presidential palace
taliban forces took over the afghan
capital of kabul on sunday seizing power
in the country after just over a week of
swift advances across afghanistan
the speed of this taliban takeover has
shocked anyone that i know who has
followed the
developments in the country and shocked
afghans in kabul
as the fighters entered the city
president ashraf ghani fled the country
and by monday morning people worried
about living under taliban rule flocked
to kabul's airport
this is all happening far faster than
u.s officials had predicted and so a lot
of questions on sunday about what went
wrong here's how the taliban's takeover
is creating new challenges for the biden
administration and an uncertain future
for the afghan people
it didn't take long before
thousands of afghans were swarming the
airport hoping to get
out on evacuation flights some people
had tickets on civilian flights that
were later cancelled overnight there was
a lot of chaos and at least three people
were killed by gunfire we're not
entirely sure by who but it's the u.s
military that has taken control of
security of the airport
meanwhile the u.s military has sent
extra american troops to afghanistan to
help facilitate this evacuation
there are currently roughly 6 000
american troops either in kabul airport
or on their way there according to us
military officials
i think another inclusive government
this is uh the demand the will and the
want of the people above one island the
taliban have said repeatedly that
afghan civilians have nothing to fear
from them they also say that girls under
the taliban will be allowed to go to
school but the fact is what we've seen
since then said kabul we've seen the
taliban raid ngo offices erect
checkpoints throughout the city
and
people are concerned that the taliban
will instate the same kind of
authoritarian rule that they had in the
90s we haven't seen large-scale violence
against civilians in kabul yet but there
is already a very pervasive sense of
fear in the capital
as a taliban advanced the u.s was
counting on afghan forces that it had
invested billions of dollars in to train
and build up over the past 20 years
is a taliban takeover of afghanistan now
inevitable no
it is not
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as quipped as any
army in the world
and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable
but afghan security forces largely
surrendered without a fight so that by
sunday taliban fighters were able to
take control of the whole country
the biden administration stood by its
decision to exit afghanistan we went to
afghanistan 20 years ago with one
mission and that mission was to deal
with the folks who attacked us on 911
and we have succeeded in that mission
perhaps the speed at which this happened
wasn't predictable but the taliban's
takeover was largely predictable and so
a lot of questions now if president
biden either didn't know about that
that's a problem with intelligence
issues or or his own policy discussions
if he did know about it and didn't care
to do more than what does it say about
his willingness to uh remain committed
and and maintain his promises to allies
around the world
the taliban's rapid takeover of
afghanistan also has implications for
the surrounding region it's the security
implications pakistan and iran and also
all the bordering countries
are terrified that
you have a refugee crisis people
spilling over the borders we're already
seeing people trying to rush out of the
country in fear of what will come